استمروا عشرات من طالب اللجوء في بلجيكا
بالاقامه في الشوارع المحيطه بمبنى اداره
اللجوء الفيدراليه للشهر الرابع على
التوالي في انتظار توفير الاماكن الاقامه
لهم وتتبادل السلطات المختلفه في بلجيكا
بين الفيدراليه والمحليه اليوم في
المسؤوليه عن الامر ياتي ذلك في وقت شهدت
فيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ازديادا في
اعداد طالب اللجوء العام الماضي مسجله
ارقام القياسيه حسب مفاوضه الشؤون
الداخليه للاتحاد التي قالت في ستوكهولم
بعد اجتماعا وزراء الداخليه والهجره ان
الدول الاتحاد قررت تسريعه عمليه الاعاده
لمن ترفض طلباته اللجوءهم وتسريع النظر
فيمن تبقى
ياتي ذلك قبل اسبوع من عقد قمه خاصه لدول
الاتحاد للنظر في ملفي اللجوء والهجره
وكاله اللجوء التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي
افادت بان اعداد طالب اللجوء ازدادت من
58000 مطلع عام 2022 لتجاوز 107,000 في
نوفمبر الماضي ما يعتبر رقما قياسيا اغلب
هؤلاء من سوريا وافغانستان انضمت دول
جديده غير معتاده الى قائمه الى القائمه
مثل مصر والمغرب وتركيا
وارتفع عدد من ينتظرون الرد على طلبات
اللجوء الى 600 وتسعه عشر الف وهو الاعلى
منذ 2017 اما نسبه القبول فوصلت الى 39 في
المئه اغلبها لقادمين من سوريا واليمن
واريتريا واوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا وشاهد
العام الماضي
والجزائر وتونس وفلسطين كما ارتفع الرقم
القادمين من دول يحق لمواطنيها دخول
الاتحاد دون تاشيره مسبقه واغلبهم من
امريكا اللاتينيه
من امام الهيئه الاتحاديه للجوء في بروكسل
مراسل الجزيره عبد الله الشامي ينضم الينا
مع حجم هذه المشكله وكيف يتم التعامل معها
عبد الله
نعم عثمان هذه المشكله هنا في بلجيكا مقر
مؤسسه الاتحاد الاوروبي ااا تراويح مكانها
منذ اكثر من سته اشهر نعلم انه هنا يعني
سنرى بعد قليل العشرات من طالبيه اللجوء
لا زالوا منذ اكثر من خمسه اشهر ينتظرون
توفير اماكن اقامه لهم والامر هنا يتم
تبادل الاتهام بمن يكون مسؤول عن ذلك ما
بين الحكومه الفيدراليه وبين حكومه اقليم
بروكسل العاصمه بين هذين الطرفين يواصل
هؤلاء الاشخاص الاقامه هنا امام هذا
المبنى الظاهر خلفي مبنى هيئه اللجوء
الاتحاديه الذي ينظر في هذه الطلبات
بالطبع الامر اللجوء الذي همم يعني سيعقد
لاجله خلال الايام المقبله سبعه ايام منذ
الان بالتحديد قمه خاصه هنا في بروكس
العلامه دار يومين هو امر ملح لدى كثير ما
قاله اوروبي كما نرى الان في الكادر هذه
الخيم التي تقع هنا قرب همم المبنى تحديدا
امطار بسيطه عن هؤلاء الاشخاص مستمرون في
البيانات هنا منذ
الصيف الماضي الكثير منهم ممن حدثناهم
يقولون انهم لا يتلقون طلبا بشان توفير
اماكن الاقامه لهم او الدعم المالي في
انتظار طلبات اللجوء او في انتظار الرد
على طلبات اللجوء كما نرى في الكادر هذا
المبنى الذي يعد المقر الاساسي لهيئه
اللجوء الفيدراليه هنا في بلجيكا كلها هذا
المبنى توقف عن النظر طلبات اللجوء وتم
تحويلها الى اماكن اخرى في بروكسل بسبب
هذه المشكله لكن الحكومه الفيدراليه هنا
تقول ان الامر ليس بسبب مشكله ماديه وانما
هو ايضا له علاقه
بمشكله من له المسؤوليه بين هذين الطرفين
تقول المؤسسات الحقوقيه العامله في هذا
الامر مساله اللجوء ان الحكومه البلجيكيه
لا تقوم بما يكفي هذه المشكله ليست هنا
بالطبع فقط في بلجيكا وانما في كثير من
الدول الاورو التي بسبب تزايد هذا الملف
كما قلت في الخبر وتزايد عدد طالبي اللجوء
ستعقد قمه اليوميه التاسع العاشر من
فبراير هنا في بروكسل لبحث هذا الامر مكان
تم اقتراعه او ما يعتقد انه سيتم الاتفاق
بشانه بهذه القمه هو ما تم مناقشته في
يومي السادس والعشريه 27 من يناير في
اجتماع وزراء الهجره والداخليه الذي عقد
في ستوكهولم حيث تقع مقر الرئاسه السويديه
الحاليه للاتحاد سيتم تسريع مساله اعاده
اللاجئين الى اوطارين من يتم رفض طلبات
اللجوءهم هذا الامر يلقى قبول الذي كثير
من الدول لانه كثير من الدول التي حتى
كانت تقليديه ان تتلقى او تقبل مزيد من
اللاجئين اصبحت الان تدفع باتجاه العكس
كما هو الحال في السويد وكذلك ايضا في دول
قريبه من هنا مثل هولندا والمانيا وكذلك
فرنسا لكن الازمه كما قلت اللجوء
الاوروبيه تقول ان الامر تزايد المشكله
تكبر وقتا عن وقته هناك
ظاهر جديده من ابرزها كما قلت ايضا دول
جديده لم يكن عاده ياتي منها المواطنون
اصبح ايضا يقدمون اللجوء مثل الدول في
شمال افريقيا ودول ايضا في امريكا
الجنوبيه شكرا عبد الله الشامي من بروكسل